peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
planar 20h45 blessés un drame de 10
secondes ce n'est pas un tremblement de
terre qui a créé ce paysage des pointes
l'écroulement de quelques caverne de
quelques galeries souterraines vestiges
des carrières de sont sortis des pierres
de paris a soudain fait craquer la
croûte de terre qui s'est affaissé de 5
à 6 mètres
un immeuble de trois étages 25 pavillons
une petite usine non plus été que des
des cons
[Musique]
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
roger frey est venu encourager les
équipes de secours qui avec un
acharnement de fourmi se sont efforcé
pendant trois jours de sauver ce qui
pouvait vivre encore sous cet
amoncellement de moellons de ciment et
de poutres
[Musique]
des blessés on en comptera définitif 45
engloutie sous leurs murs des morts on
en comptera 20 enfouis dans cet
entonnoir soudainement creusé sur une
superficie de 6 hectares et au delà de
ces deuils brutaux il y à l'immense
tragédie des gens qui ont perdu un père
ou un enfant
le drame de ceux à qui il ne reste rien
de ce qui faisait leur vie quotidienne
spectacle dramatique spectacle affreux
on reste sans voix devant un désastre
hausse inattendue aussi inimaginable
[Musique]
versailles était le dernier des corps
est le dernier acte de la visite du
président des états unis à paris et à
travers cette admirable toile de fond on
a pu voir le général de gaulle et madame
kennedy ouvrir le cortège qui allaient
circonstances dont la rareté fait aussi
le prix dîner dans la galerie des glaces
ferment le cycle des entretiens de paris
cette brillante soirée était la préface
d'un autre cycle celui de vienne où
monsieur khrouchtchev et monsieur
kennedy s'était donné rendez vous un
premier entretien ce la seule à
l'ambassade américaine en précédait un
autre à l'ambassade soviétique
de ces conversations laborieuse il ne
sortirait qu'un geste de bonne volonté
et une espérance c'est déjà quelque
chose car la soirée de schönbrunn qui
terminait ces deux journées et où les
deux cas routes chauffées kennedy
étaient les hôtes du président enchères
se terminaient un sourire de part et
d'autre on le sait la diplomatie n'en
n'est pas avare mais c'est dans ce
sourire de khrouchtchev à madame kennedy
ce sourire de kennedy à madame coach of
qu'on peut peut être mieux que dans les
communiqués lire un peu l'espérance du
monde et deux tiers de la population du
globe souffre encore aujourd'hui de la
faim ce thème affligeant monsieur
terrenoire ministre de l'information a
développé devant la presse en donnant le
départ d'une grande collecte qui doit
permettre à la france d'apporter sa
participation à la campagne mondiale
contre la faim
au palais de justice de paris le rideau
est tombé sur le procès au lourd dossier
de 2 des responsables du putsch d'alger
les juges du tribunal militaire n'auront
siégé que trois jours pour rendre leur
jugement après avoir entendu le
procureur besson leur dire
après des semaines de réflexion et de
drames de conscience je ne me sens pas
le droit de réclamer la peine de mort
quinze ans de réclusion
c'est par cette condamnation qui atteint
maurice challe et andré zeller que s'est
terminé ce procès exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bourget le salon international de
l'aéronautique est arrivé à son terme
deux journées de parade aérienne à la
première de ces journées on a pu voir
sans donner le bombardier américain p 58
qui reliait new york à paris en trois
heures enfin on ne devait hélas plus le
revoir
dans la campagne on n'a retrouvé que des
débris tout ce qui restait de l'appareil
et de son équipage ce drame qui garde
son mystère ne devait pas arrêter la
présentation on devait voir tour à tour
le singulier breguet 940 capable
d'atterrir en quelques mètres
un appareil moins exigeante encore le
short sc un britannique qui décolle et
atterrit à la verticale avec le griffon
monoplace à aile delta et antenna canard
commencer la série des prototypes
français qui ambitionne des vitesses de
2500 km heure c'est ainsi qu'après le
mirage iii appareils d'intervention qui
équipe l'armée française et qui lui a
servi de modèle
on a pu voir le mirage quatre
biréacteurs premier bombardier atomique
européen
95 appareils les plus rapides les plus
gros ou les plus révolutionnaires ont
ainsi inscrit dans le ciel du bourget
les promesses de l'aviation
[Musique]
deux cent cinquante mille personnes de
générations de reine la reine elizabeth
et sa mère pour assister au derby
d'epsom qui consacre le meilleur cheval
de la cèze 30 chevaux au départ pour
2400 mètres de course au bout desquels
se trouve une petite fortune
60 millions au vainqueur des x donner le
vertige à tous et jockeys qui prennent
le départ tambour battant
beaucoup de chevaux français dans ce
peloton et parmi eux quelques favoris
enfonçant rangs serrés comme un
reichshoffen personne ne se détache tout
le monde veut gagner de fait chacun des
chevaux peut encore prétendre gagner
tous les favoris sont là et aussi à
cheval que personne n'attend psyllium
quelques coups de cravache de son choc
et roger poincelet pour 60 millions ça
en vaut la peine
epci diom coiffe tout le monde sur le
poteau la reine est déçu son favori et
bac pro taxi diom sépare des ruades
coquine qu'il manifeste sa joie avec
roger poincelet
il a joué un bon tour à tous les
parieurs
match de la dernière chance pour le
racing club de paris maillot clair
devant l'équipe du havre une dernière
chance que les joueurs parisiens ont
l'air de vouloir saisir du bout des
pieds
[Applaudissements]
ils mènent rapidement par 1 à 0 du
racing un racing qui n'aurait pas dû
attendre la dernière journée du
championnat de france pour essayer de
décrocher le titre de champions 2 0 les
parisiens sont bien partis ils sont
champions de france du moins
momentanément
d'autant qu'à monaco les monégasques eux
sous le regard sévère de leur souverain
peine visiblement devant valenciennes
maillot français comme les monégasques
mais parements blancs sur la poitrine
monaco doit absolument gagner s'ils ne
veut pas laisser le titre de champion de
france au parisien et pour le moment il
n'en prend pas le chemin
et pourtant c'est un incident le jeu qui
va donner la victoire aux monégasques
faible de valenciennes suivi d'un
contrat
[Applaudissements]
garnier ma pour monaco un but qui vaut
un titre de champion pendant ce temps au
havre le racing baisse les bras tous ses
espoirs se sont envolés les havrais en
profite ce sont eux qui s'amusent
maintenant et qui marque successivement
deux bus qui leur donne un match nul
[Applaudissements]
hu à l'équipe
si monaco c'est l'heure du triomphe pour
la première fois ils sont champions de
france
le rideau vient se baisser sur une
saison fertile en émotions
à ce pacifique lâcher de ballons succès
d'un spectacle qui l'est beaucoup moins
les trente trois monstres en forme de
voiture qui participent aux 500 miles d
indianapolis sont lâches pour le moment
avec leurs 400 chevaux sous le capot
ils sont encore bien sam
pas pour longtemps ce serait 3
voilà le festival commun
[Musique]
inutile de vous déranger messieurs il
n'y a que des blessés légers
ça fait cependant cinq concurrentes
moins sur le circuit où les rescapés
continuent de rouler à plus de 200
valent quand les monstres ne tourne pas
ce sont les mécanos qui bat des records
de vitesse en quelques secondes on vous
fait le plein et on vous change de 4 on
ne reste plus grand monde sur la piste à
la fin de l'épreuve 12 voitures
franchissent la ligne d'arrivée
ces fêtes qui terminent le premier qui
gagne les 50 millions du vainqueur ce
qui somme toute n'est peut-être pas trop
pour ce qu il a risqué
[Musique]
c'est ici en ami et un frère que je me
présente avait dit à son arrivée
monsieur houphouët boigny président de
la république de côte d'ivoire
paroles que devait confirmer et son
geste de piété devant la tombe du soldat
inconnu et ses entretiens avec le
général de gaulle la visite de monsieur
houphouët boigny à paris devait être le
prétexte à une grande réception à
l'elysée à laquelle assistait le monde
de la politique et de la diplomatie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et également par une soirée de gala à
l'opéra où ils ont pu voir selon les
paroles du général de gaulle
outre l'appareil officielle qui marque
toute la considération de mon pays pour
le vôtre le cortège de nos centimes 1
d'exceptionnel amitié mais la définition
de la république de côte d'ivoire
n'est-elle pas d'être un symbole de la
nouvelle afrique ami de la france au
vatican une autre visite a fait quelques
bruits celle que le roi baudouin et la
reine fabiola accompagné des membres du
gouvernement belge ont fait au pape jean
xxiii
on avait observé que pour cette
circonstance la cérémonie avait été
allégé
portes ouvertes aux suppositions le
souverain pontife devait bientôt
d'ailleurs n'est confirmé lui-même en
annonçant la future naissance d'un
héritier au trône de belgique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cathédrale dior n'avait pas vu tel
mariage princier depuis le 15e siècle
la reine elizabeth la reine-mère le
prince philippe et la famille royale au
grand complet
ils ont assisté à la cérémonie qui a uni
le duc de kent à la ravissante
catharines worsley lointaine descendante
de cromwell
[Musique]
voici donc celui qui fut l'enfant
terrible de la famille royale
aujourd'hui âgé de 25 ans et capitaine
des royals scotch breizh parfaitement
assagi est tout prêt à être bon époux en
attendant d'être bon pain
[Musique]
l'élection de miss europe aura été l'un
des pôles d'attraction de la quinzaine
du liban c'est à beyrouth en effet qu'un
jury éclectique utah peser les avantages
de 17me européenne qui se disputaient le
titre de miss europe
la blonde isobel dobson qui défendait
les couleurs de l'angleterre et la brune
yvette de grenon qui défendent est celle
de la france ne manquait sans doute pas
d'arguments
[Musique]
mais c'est l'allemande ina grün mockel 1
m 77 90 cm de tour de poitrine 58 de
tour de taille et 19 points qui a enlevé
le titre de miss haut rhin les fusée de
longue portée atlas sont elles aussi des
vedettes en leur genre il leur arrive en
effet d'être capricieuse c'est ainsi que
l'armée de l'air us à vue à sa place à
van gogh un million et demi de dollars
disparaître en fumée
les spécialistes américains ont pu se
féliciter d'avoir confié la capsule de
shepard à une fusée redstone plutôt qu'à
une fusée atlas comme il l'avait prévu
initialement
la bretagne bouge la bretagne des choux
fleurs des pommes de terre et des
artichauts l'an dernier lui avait fallu
faute d'un prix sinon intéressant du
moins possible jeter des tonnes
d'artichaut cette année elle a bougé
pour des pommes de terre qu'elle est
amenée à vendre à perte
il ya donc un problème de la bretagne
mais il va plus loin que la pomme de
terre et l'artichaut
que sait-on de la bretagne pour la
plupart la bretagne est un beau pays un
peu triste un pays de l'un des deux
jeunes est qu'on chantait les romances
populaire le pays des menhirs et des
dolmens cher aux amateurs d'antiquités
celtique un pays de côtes déchiquetées
battu par une mère romantique alors que
dans les peintures des grèves s'élève
une race de chevaux particulièrement
robustes les seuls dit on qui
résistaient à la retraite de russie un
pays a pas de vieilles pierres ou les
remparts des cités et les tour des
châteaux qui raconte des histoires
toujours tragique fond pendant aux
églises qui semble voguer sur les
prairies ou rumine ses vaches blanches
et noires qui ont leur place d'honneur
au palmarès des pauvres de l'imagerie
encore les clochers à jour et les
calvaires aux mille personnages les
pardons les bines loose et les coiffes
c'est cela la bretagne pour beaucoup
mais en vérité ce n'est pas cela la
bretagne est un problème national dans
l'artichaut et la pomme de terre ne sont
que des éléments symptomatique
tous ces villages aux noms anker ample
ou en loques se dépeuple 20000 breton
quittent chaque année leurs maisons et
leurs commerces d'un autre âge
pourquoi c'est que la bretagne et d'un
demi-siècle en retard et qu'elle
domisiel alors que tout a marché à pas
de géant la bretagne a toujours des
chaumières
la moitié des maisons devrait être
reconstruite les deux tiers n'ont pas
l'eau courante
[Musique]
pays spécifiquement agricole les
exploitations victime d'un morcellement
abusif ne sont pas susceptibles d'une
exploitation rationnelle aussi les
machines sont elles rares et la culture
se fait toujours de façon artisanale
comme voici cent ans c'est à dire comme
au moyen-age
si les exploitations moderne secondes
que dire de l'équipement général les
routes sont mauvaises plus mal
entretenue que dans les autres contrées
par des cantonniers aussi archaïque
qu'un puissant
[Musique]
les canaux embourbé leur écluses rouillé
ne semble plus utilisé et chose plus
étonnante encore à notre siècle vitesse
le train n'est de la gare montparnasse à
la gare de brest deux minutes de plus
qu'en 1935
ajoutons que sur le réseau breton la
voie étroite tient tête à la voie
normale avec tout ce que cela comporte
de difficultés et de transbordement
superflu
c'est ont aussi que le charbon se vend
plus cher ici que dans le reste de la
france
alors rien et désespéré sans doute et
nous verrons prochainement les chances
de la bretagne
mais cet écriteau pour l'heure qui pour
at-il intéressé
des bolides la belle époque qu'on
retrouvait pour un temps l'âme de leur
jeunesse ils sont 46 cas autant
crachotant qui effectue le rallye
bruxelles/paris madre vitesse imposée 25
kilomètres à l'heure ce qui permet de
musarder chemin faisant et même de
rendre hommage aux pionniers en passant
[Musique]
on
sur les routes espagnoles on a parfois
dépassé le 100 à l'heure dans les
descentes pas par imprudence mais parce
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire autrement
les fera en effet était tous un peu
atteindre rhumatismes madre tout le
monde descend
il y a presque autant de monde sur le
parcours pour 24 heures du mans c'est
une renault 19 ans qui a joué les
ferrari de la belle époque en remportant
l'épreuve
baylet sont là souffrir un peu elle en a
bien besoin à son âge
[Musique]
le mans capitale mondiale de
l'automobile pour 24 heures 10 m de
course à pied et en avant pour la grande
randonnée on est tout de suite dans le
vif du sujet les 55 quart temps mais
déjà pleins gaz et ferrari sont venus en
masse sur le circuit alors quoi
d'étonnant à ce que le domine la course
dès les premières heures
est ce qu'il ya de merveilleux c'est que
ce sont deux pilotes de la classe
biberon des frères rodrigues ils sont 19
et 22 ans qui anime les preuves pendant
22 heures
on va croire qu'ils vont gagner
[Musique]
et voici en tête de la brochette des
ferrari c'est entre ces trois voitures
que se joue la première place
soyez maître de votre vitesse un conseil
que ne suivent pas tous les pilotes
il est vrai que la pluie c'est une
tradition au mans ne facilite pas la
tâche des concurrents plusieurs voitures
vont dans le décor les blessés vont s'en
tirer sans trop de mal
après quelques jours d'hôpital un départ
numéro 48 montre le bout de son nez
l'équipement électrique est un élément
essentiel de réussite aux 24 heures du
mans personne ne l'a oublié
on ne peut pas tourner 24 heures se
ravitailler ce qui n'a pas empêché
certains pilotes à prévoyant ginter et
von trips ce de tomber en panne
d'essence c'est vraiment le comble et
pendant ce temps cinq petites voitures
françaises sur six au départ des db
panhard grignote des kilomètres à près
de 150 de moyenne c'est encore plus
extraordinaire que la victoire des
ferrari consécration de la robustesse de
la mécanique de la pl 17 la voiture de
monsieur tout le monde
la victoire de la db panhard numéro 53
qui termine première à l' indice de
performance
quant à la ferrari des vainqueurs philly
les gens de bien c'est une même un engin
qui n'est pas à la portée de toutes les
bourses
[Musique]
face à la crypte du mont valérien vous
propose 17 fusillés de la résistance le
général de gaulle a comme chaque année
en cette date anniversaire ranimer la
flamme sacrée pugilat fraternellement
saluer les compagnons de la libération
et s'est mêlé à la foule il ya 21 ans à
cette même date la france n'avait pas
abdiqué
après les fatigues protocolaire de paris
de vienne et de londres mais c'est
jacqueline kennedy a fait un crochet par
la grèce où elle a été reçue par le roi
poehl et la reine frederick à
[Musique]
et
la première dame des etats-unis à
visiter en toute simplicité les ruines
de l'acropole et après avoir déclaré
qu'elle était pleine d'admiration pour
la grèce elle a formé le projet d'y
envoyer ses enfants en vacances
[Musique]
cette image du président kennedy
utilisant le monde charles de l'aéroport
pour descendre de son avion a beaucoup
ému l'amérique
rien de grave ont affirmé les médecins
mais tous les américains qui a
impressionné la paire de béquilles
voudrait désormais voir leurs jeunes
présidents se ménager davantage et se
reposer plus souvent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la visite que la pince renier la
princesse grace de monaco ont rendu à
l'irlande
wright est aussi pour la princesse une
sorte de retour aux sources l'irlande se
trouve être en effet le berceau de la
famille kelly et il n'y a guère que 80
ans que le grand père de la princesse
grace s'expatria pour l'amérique
voilà pourquoi les irlandais ont pu à
travers les quelques cinquante mille
kelly que l'on dénombre encore en
irlande avoir la sensation de retrouver
dans l'autre du président de valera une
parente lointaine
[Musique]
il ya maintenant deux ans qui a commencé
du côté français ce 13e travail
d'hercule
ouvrir une route sous le plus haut
sommet d'europe deux ans que les
compresseurs de 1900 chauveau fabrique
l'air comprimé nécessaires à la
machinerie qui travaillent dans les
entrailles de la montagne
chaque jour depuis les hommes du tunnel
sont allés retrouver leur chantier
souterrain
quelques mètres plus loin que la veille
aujourd'hui des 11 km 6 ans les français
ont grignoté 3500 mètres soit 352 plus
que l'équipe italienne qui commençait à
huit mois plus tôt
[Musique]
cette avance les équipes françaises la
doivent au jumbo énorme bâti à trois
étages hérissée de 16 perforatrice qui
attaquent la roche simultanément
l'action des explosifs disposés dans les
140 pour ainsi percé ouvre chaque fois
une brèche de 4 m
soit 750 tonnes de matériaux que deux
pelles mécaniques auront ensuite à
évacuer relayé par les tapis roulants
et 90 wagonnets ainsi le chantier avance
de 7 à 8 mètres par jour sous 3000
mètres de montagne
[Musique]
cependant vers l'amont cette image
infernal s'apaisent c'est ici un autre
chantier et la roche torture et fait
place à la voûte de béton le tunnel a
déjà pris sa forme définitive celle que
connaîtront les automobilistes de 1963
car il faudra attendre cette date pour
voir les touristes succédèrent aux
camions sur la route qui mènera de
chamonix en italie à travers le mont
blanc
[Musique]
chaque jour a vu une nouvelle cité
bretonne investi par les commandos
d'agriculteurs guingamp après morlaix
lannion et pontivy à pontivy pour la
première fois la manifestation devait
dégénérer en violences que veulent donc
ses hommes en colère des satisfactions
immédiates
certes mais derrière cette jacquerie se
profile nous l'avons constaté la semaine
dernière tout un problème breton un
problème qui dépasse le prix de la pomme
de terre
malgré les 12 cents tracteurs les
manifestants déchaînés de pontivy c'est
le problème de la bretagne déshérités
et si les paysans bretons se sont
attaqués aux lignes téléphoniques
c'est paradoxalement pour protester
contre leur rareté que les châteaux
d'eau phyllis de pousser les fils
électriques de tendre leurs toiles nous
allons voir que la bretagne ne manque
pourtant pas de chance pour rattraper
son retard
s'il est vrai que le revenu de 50 % des
agriculteurs bretons est inférieur au
salaire du manoeuvre léger c'est en
bretagne aussi qu'on trouve les fermes
modèles les mieux équipés
[Musique]
la production agricole bretonne est en
passe de dépasser la moitié de la
production totale de la france la pêche
de son côté n'est pas seulement une
attraction pour touristes
mais j'en atout important qui peut
toujours être joué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
si les pêcheurs bretons ont eu de la
peine à sortir de leurs traditions
artisanales les fabriques de lorient
débite aujourd'hui des centaines de
tonnes de glace quotidiennement des
chalutiers équipés de radios et de
sondes pour la détection des bancs de
poissons font désormais la loi et la
modernisation de la flotte bretonne qui
entre deux chiffres 8000 navire en 39
ramener 81 mille tonnes de poissons 5000
navire maintenant on ramène 150 mille
tonnes
à la modernisation de la flotte il faut
ajouter aussi l'aménagement des
campagnes de pêche qui permet d'étaler
sur l'année des arrivages qu'ils
n'étaient que saisonnier et si la
tradition de la criée garde toujours sa
place dans les moeurs de la pêche
l'industrie des conserves peut
aujourd'hui la plupart du temps
fonctionné à plein temps c'est du reste
de l'industrie que la bretagne peut
attendre beaucoup
[Musique]
les exemples de décentralisation
industrielle vers la bretagne se sont
jusqu'ici compté lusine flaminaire en
est un avec ses 700 ouvriers
elle a fait d'heureux dont l'une des
capitales européennes du briquet
[Musique]
il faudrait 10 il faudrait 20 redon nous
verrons prochainement les espoirs que la
bretagne peut nourrir dans ce domaine
moyennant quoi une autre carte bretonne
qui s'appelle brest pourrait être joué
doté d'un arrière pays industrialisés
brest qui doit à la guerre d'être une
ville toute neuve pourrait prétendre un
autre avenir que celui de port militaire
[Musique]
le belge olivier gendebien et l'allemand
von trips ce rêve
l'américain phil hill plus prosaïque et
déjà au volant de sa ferrari il est le
premier dans sa voiture au départ du
grand prix de belgique il sera encore le
premier à l'arrivée
certes les deux rêveurs gendebien et von
trips ne vont pas lui laisser le temps
de respirer il devra appuyer à fond sur
l'accélérateur
tout cela se passe à plus de 200 6 de
moyenne
mais
fini les femmes clipse ginter numéro 6
juin devient numéro 8 il ya la queue des
fils harry car ce grand prix de belgique
c'est le triomphe des voitures
italiennes qui prennent les quatre
premières places
quant à phil hill il pourrait bien être
cette année le premier pilote américain
champion du monde
[Musique]
toujours de la pointe du progrès voilà
ce que vous propose cette année les
américains pour vos vacances tout
d'abord des jolies filles et puis ce
petit divertissement
ça ne demande pas des qualités
intellectuelles exceptionnelles ce n'est
pas dangereux enfin ça peut se pratiquer
n'importe où pourvu que ce soit en
pleine et une latte de plastique spécial
un peu au dessus voilà comment on trouve
son âme d'enfant
il paraît que ce jeu va faire fureur sur
les plages du monde entier cet été
pourquoi pas après tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hippodrome de longchamp s'est mise en
robe d'été pour la plus grande course de
l'année le grand prix de paris
c'est sur vos départs 40 millions au
bout de la ligne droite des tribunes
après 3000 m de galop sous un soleil de
plomb du plomb les concurrents non sous
leurs sabots le train n'est pas très
rapide
c'est peut-être pour faire durer le
plaisir les turfistes ont ainsi quelques
secondes supplémentaires de rêve de fait
on reste très groupée dans le peloton
c'est toujours le délai de grâce jusqu'à
la ligne droite où les coeurs commence à
battre un peu plus vite les 40 millions
c'est pour bientôt et bien avant la
ligne d'arrivée c'est déjà pour balto
que montrent maxime garcia
l'heureuse élue comme dans un fauteuil
avec quatre longueurs d'avancé
[Musique]
ermenonville en cinq petites escale chez
jean richard qui fête en compagnie de
quelques amis le cinquième anniversaire
de son réseau outre les animaux sauvages
en richard n'a pas oublié les monstres
sacrés qui eux n'ont pas besoin de 15 sa
part et méchant mais c'est tout temps
dans ces petites bêtes là alors là
georges guétary soyez prudents ce gentil
petit pensionnaire pèse 400 kg fait le
beau pour voir un peu et oui c'est l'un
des plus grandioses du monde de mettre
60 des pieds à la tête
avec lui pas de danger il est très
sociable et plein de malice avec cela
pas encore majeur mais déjà fumeurs
comme un homme
[Musique]
aux yeux du monde
la visite qui a fait à paris le
président de la république ouest
allemande monsieur luc haute avec son
épouse du général de gaulle or a
souligné un événement d'importance
l'une des plus audacieuses
réconciliation de l'histoire
cet arc de triomphe où monsieur luc que
s'est recueilli sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu qu on a pu mesurer tout le
chemin parcouru par deux pays déchiré en
moins d'un siècle par trois guerres
monsieur léopold senghor président de la
république du sénégal avait revêtu ce
jour-là sap toge et son hermine de
professeurs de lettres pour présider à
la distribution des prix dans un lycée
de dakar dans une époque trop souvent
troublées par des antagonismes ratio on
peut constater que parmi tous ces
adolescents
personne ne songeait à la différence de
couleur de peau personne ne songeait à
la considérer comme autre chose que ce
qu'elle ait une différence de
pigmentation
c'est un des exemples les plus
réjouissant que donne aujourd'hui les
pays africains de langue française
[Musique]
abbas les directeurs de cinéma ont
obtenu leur 16e congrès au cours duquel
ils se sont élevés contre la fiscalité
et les films audacieux où il voit les
deux mots du septième art entre deux
réunions ils ont aussi sacrifié à la
tradition champenoise en visitant les
caves ce qui en aucun cas ne saurait
être considérée comme une audace
à saint symphorien en eure et loir
monsieur robert buron ministre des
travaux publics a inauguré en compagnie
notamment de son excellence le général
kevin ambassadeur des états unis
le buste élevé à la mémoire du général
patton tatane le nom d'un char sans
doute mais aussi celui du héros de la
percée d'avranches un nom qu'en france
on ne peut oublier le nouveau musée du
havre a été inaugurée par monsieur andré
malraux avec son signal de 200 tonnes il
sera le premier bâtiment qu'on
découvrira du large toutes ensemble
musée et maison de la culture
c'est là une création unique dans son
genre un musée révolutionnaire qu'on dit
en avance de 50 ans avec des panneaux
escamotable et des balcons sur deux
faces tout en acier et en verre et qui
est le 900 38e musées français
[Musique]
tandis que l'agitation paysanne gagnait
d'autres régions les agriculteurs
bretons ont perdu à morlaix leur
principale raison de manifester le
tribunal a acquitté messieurs gourvennec
et leon
relax et des fins de poursuites comme
dit la sentence les deux dirigeants se
sont retrouvés libre au milieu de dix
mille paysans bretons est ce la masse de
la détente chez ces derniers mais nous
avons vu la semaine dernière que le mal
dont souffre la bretagne n'est pas que
d'ordre agricole
ces provinces de france qui est la plus
particulariser dont l'ancien parlement
de rennes et les jetons de présence à
l'éffigie de louis saez rappelle son
attachement à ses libertés et qui a
gardé le privilège de conserver sa
langue est trop longtemps passé à côté
du progrès mais la situation n'est pas
sans espoir
un service régulier d'avion fonctionne
depuis cette année c'est déjà un progrès
et c'est une promesse d'avenir que
l'importante usines d'automobiles que
citoyenne achève aux portes de rennes
le premier gros consommateurs de main
d'oeuvre qui permettra qui permet déjà
d'amorcer la diminution d'une émigration
qui atteint le chiffre impressionnant de
vingt mille exilés volontaires par an
on s d'avenir encore le chantier de la
rance qui dotera la bretagne de la
première centrale marémotrice du monde
et les sondages de brennilis qui sont à
l'origine de la centrale nucléaire
expérimental au pied des monts d'arrée
promesses plus immédiate et plus
efficaces aussi la centrale à turbines à
gaz de bresse pordic qui fonctionnera
suivant le principe des moteurs à
réaction et qui aura une puissance de 20
mille kilos à guingamp où se concentrent
chaque jour des cageots empli de poulet
c'est déjà une réalité
guingamp est aujourd'hui une espèce de
chicago du poulet électrocuté seigner et
chaud des plumes et 200000 infortunés
poulet passent chaque semaine dans la
chaîne infernale emporté au rythme
ininterrompu de l'automation étrange et
inquiétant dallest qui nous importe bien
loin de l'image de la bretagne
traditionnels
l'enchanteur merlin et la fée viviane
ont depuis longtemps déserté la forêt de
brocéliande et leur baguette magique et
casser les tours du château d'anne de
bretagne n'abrite plus que des souvenirs
et du déclin comme les jacques cartier
les surcouf les duguay trouin reste
comme le symbole du caractère breton on
a pu comparer à ce granit dont on a
rebâti saint malo seul aujourd'hui
l'énergie qui anime les usines réalisera
le miracle qu'attend la bretagne donner
à cette terre de tradition de caractère
sa place dans le monde moderne
[Musique]
au liban byblos offre à celui qui
emprunte le chemin des barques
phénicienne bien autre chose que le
pittoresque d'un quelconque ports de la
côte méditerranéenne
une confrontation avec 7000 ans
d'histoire
les fouilles menées depuis 40 ans par
des archéologues français sur l'antique
acropole ont fait surgir les vestiges
superposés d'une vingtaine de
civilisation et on y découvre
aujourd'hui des poteries vieille de sept
mille ans ainsi devant les restes des
maisons phénicienne peut-on rêver aux
hommes d'il ya 50 siècles qui enterrait
encore leur mort dans les jardins mais
stick
quelques pins et on peut évoquer la
grandeur de rome qui édifia là aussi son
théâtre antique et ses temples
[Musique]
quelques pas encore au delà d'une
sculpture brisé et voici révélé le temps
des croisades avec les fortifications
franck qui sacrifièrent les colonnes
romaines à leurs remparts et qui
marquèrent la fin de quatre cent
soixante sept ans de domination arabe
dont au fond du puits du roi le tombeau
date sheeran conserve la trace
byblos un prodigieux raccourcie de sept
mille ans de l'histoire des hommes
[Musique]